let's do a slightly more complicated
two-dimensional projectile motion
problem now so in this situation i am
going to
i am going to launch the projectile off
of a platform
off of a platform and then it is going
to land on another platform it is going
to land on another platform and i'm
going to fire the projectile i'm going
to fire the projectile
at an angle let me draw this a little
bit better
so i'm going to fire the projectile at
an angle of let me use a not so clean
number let's say it is 53 it's a 53
degree angle
and it's coming out of the cannon
so
and the and let me make it clear so it's
coming out let me do it this way
just to make it a hundred percent clear
so
so this angle right over here is 53
degrees
53 degrees and we are going to
have it come out of the muzzle of the
cannon with a velocity of
90 meters per second 90
meters per second and just to give
ourselves a sense of the heights or how
high it's being launched from so the
from the muzzle of the cannon down to
here so this height right over here
this height right over there let's say
that that is 25 meters
and let's say that this height right
over here
this height right over here let's say
that that is 9 meters
9 meters and so we're essentially
launching this from a height of 25
meters i know in the last video
in the last video even though i drew the
canon like this we assumed that it was
being launched from an altitude of zero
and then landing back at an altitude of
zero here
we're assuming we're launching it from
an altitude of 25 meters because that's
when it's leaving the muzzle and it's
going to start decelerating at least in
the vertical direction as soon as it
leaves the muzzle
and then we're assuming it's not going
to land back at the same altitude it's
going to land at a different altitude so
how do we think about this problem so
the first thing you'll always want to do
is is divide your velocity vector into
its horizontal and vertical components
you use a vertical component to figure
out how long it's going to stay in the
air and then you use the horizontal
component to figure out given how long
it's in the air how far did it travel
and once again we're going to assume
that air resistance is negligible
so just based on what we did in the last
video and i'll work through it
relatively
i'll go through all of the steps in this
one as well
the vertical so if we draw our vector
we had our our vector the length here is
going to be 90.
the angle over here this is our velocity
vector the angle over here between the
x-axis and our vector is 53 degrees
and let me draw the horizontal component
the horizontal component would look like
this
and the vertical component i'll do it in
orange the vertical component would look
like that's not orange the vertical
component will look like the vertical
component would look like this
and so the vertical component of the
vector what would be the length of this
side right over here well this is the
opposite side
this is the opposite side we know from
from basic trigonometry sine of an angle
is opposite over the hypotenuse
so we know
that we know that the sine
the sine of 53 degrees is equal to this
opposite side is equal to
is equal to the vertical velocity is
equal to the vertical velocity and
it i i won't well is equal to the
vertical velocity and i could write it
it's the magnitude of the vertical
velocity i write that subscript y
because we're in the y direction that's
the vertical direction
over
the length of the hypotenuse over the
magnitude of our original vector
or we can get
we can get that this side right over
here if we multiply both sides by 90 we
get that the magnitude of that side
is going to be equal to
is equal to 90
times the sine of 53 degrees 90 times
the sine of 53 degrees now if we want to
if we want to do the horizontal
component the horizontal side is
adjacent to this
cosine so katoa cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse
is adjacent over hypotenuse so the
component
the
the horizontal component of our velocity
i'll say in the x direction
over the hypotenuse over 90
over 90 is equal to the cosine of 53. is
equal to the cosine of 53 degrees cosine
is adjacent over hypotenuse adjacent
that's this length over 90. multiply
both sides by 90 you get that the
horizontal component the horizontal
component is equal to
90 is equal to 90 times cosine of 53
degrees
times the cosine of 53 degrees
now how do we figure out how long this
thing stays in the air well we'll use
the vertical component for that
we'll use the vertical component for
that and since we're dealing especially
since we're dealing with different
levels we can't use that more basic
reasoning that hey whatever velocity we
start off at it's going to be the same
velocity but in the opposite direction
or the same magnitude of velocity but
the opposite direction because we're not
going to the same elevation what we
could do is we can use the formula that
we derived in the previous in the
previous video that the displacement let
me just copy and paste this a little bit
lower so we can use it
so let me copy it and then let me
paste it
so i'll stick it right over here so we
could use this
we know that the displacement is equal
to the initial velocity and we're
dealing with the vertical direction
right here times the change in time plus
the acceleration times the change in
time squared divided by 2. so how do we
use this to figure out how long we're in
the air so what is the displacement if
we're starting at 25 meters we're
starting at 25 meters high and we're
going to 9 meters high
so over the course while this thing is
traveling it will displace
it will be displaced downwards
16 meters it will be displaced downwards
16 meters or another way to think about
it is
our displacement our displacement in the
vertical direction is going to be equal
to negative 16 meters let me write that
a little bit bigger
negative 16 meters right because 25
minus 9 is 16.
and so
we can put that into the formula that we
derived in the previous video we get
negative 16 i won't write the units here
just so that it we don't make things too
too we don't take up too much real
estate so at least it looks simple
is equal to the initial velocity we're
dealing with just the vertical dimension
here so we're just dealing with the
vertical
we're just dealing with the vertical
here and remember it's negative because
it's our displacement is going to be
downwards we're we're losing altitude so
our vertical velocity we already figured
that out it is 90 times the sine of 53
degrees 90 times the sine of 53
degrees actually let me do it in that
same color
the first time we do a new type of
problem it's good to know what so 90
times the sine of 53 degrees times our
change in time
times our change in time is equal to the
acceleration of
of due to the force of gravity for an
object in free fall is going to be
negative 9.8 meters per second squared
but we're dividing that by 2. so we're
going to have negative 4.9
minus 4.9
meters per second squared times delta t
squared times our change in time squared
times our change in time squared so how
do we solve something like this there
you can't just factor out a t and solve
it but you might recognize this is a
quadratic equation right over here and
the way you solve quadratic equations is
you get everything onto one side of this
equation and then
you either factor it out but more likely
in this situation you we will use the
quadratic formula which we've proved in
other videos and hopefully give you the
intuition for it
to actually solve for the times where
your elevation where your displacement
in the vertical direction is negative 60
meters and you'll get two solutions here
and one of the solutions will be a
negative change in time so it'll be like
if you're going at this at some time in
the past you're also at negative 16
meters that's nonsensical for this
problem so we'll want to take the
positive value here so let's put all of
this on one side of the let's put it all
on one side of the equation so let's add
16 to both sides
let's add 16 to both sides on the left
hand side you just get a 0
0 is equal to and i'll write it in kind
of the traditional way that we're used
to seeing it i'll write the highest
degree term first so negative 4.9
times delta t squared times delta t
squared and then we have plus
90 sine of 53 degrees
plus
sine
of 53 degrees
90 sine of 53 degrees times delta t
times delta t
times delta t and then plus sixteen
plus sixteen i wanna do that in yellow
plus sixteen all of this is equal to
zero and this once again is just a
quadratic equation we can find its roots
then and the roots will be in terms of
delta t we can solve for delta t using
the quadratic formula
so we get delta t
delta t and if this is very unfamiliar
to you review the videos on khan academy
the algebra playlist on the quadratic
formula if you don't know where it came
from we also prove it for you so it's
equal to negative b b is this term right
here the coefficient on the delta t so
it's going to be negative
90 sine
of 53 degrees i'll write the quadratic
formula up here for for those of you who
aren't
who don't fully remember it so if i'm
trying to solve a
x squared plus b x plus c is equal to 0
the roots over here are going to be
negative b
plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4 ac
all of that over
all of that over 2 times a these are
going to be the x values that satisfy
this equation up here so that's all i'm
doing over here this is the b value
negative b
negative b plus or minus
plus or minus it's going to turn out
that we only care about the plus one
because that's going to give us the
positive value but i'll just write it
out here plus or minus the square root
the square root of b squared so it's
this quantity squared
so it is 90 sine
of 53 degrees squared
minus 4 we're going to run out a little
space
so minus 4
minus 4
times a which is negative 4.9 so we can
make it this well let me just write
negative 4.9
times c
c over here is 16
times 16. let me put this radical all
the way over here all of that over 2 a
all of that over 2 a
so a is negative 4.9 2 times a is
negative
negative 9.8
so now we can get the calculator out to
figure out our change in time and i'm
just going to focus on the positive
version of it i'll leave it up to you to
find the negative version and see that
will give you a negative value for
change in time and that's nonsensical so
we only care about the positive change
in time where we get to a change in or
do we get to a displacement of negative
16 meters let's get the calculator out
so we get i want to do this carefully
we have negative 90
sine of 53 degrees
plus i'm doing the plus version here
because that'll give us the positive
value plus the square root
of
the square root of and i'll do this in
parentheses 90
sine of 53 degrees
squared that's that part right there
these two negatives cancel out so i can
say this is plus 4 times positive 4.9 so
plus
4 times 4.9
times
and then that closes off our entire
radical
and so this will give me the numerator
up here
that gives me the numerator and then i
want to divide that by
by i want to divide that by did i do the
negative 90
oh and i just realized that i made a
mistake i i said that the positive
version would give you would give you
the positive time but now we realize
that's wrong because when i took the
positive version when i put a plus up
here i get a positive 2.14 for the
numerator but then we divide it by
negative 9.8 we're going to get a
negative value so that's not going to be
the time that we care about we care
about the time where this is a negative
value so let me
re-enter that so let me do the negative
value so
let me move back a little bit
and then let me
let me replace this with a minus sign
replace this with a minus sign so i'm
going to look at the negative value
because i want the positive time and so
now my numerator here is a negative
value and so this is actually what we
care about we care about the numerator
is a negative value you divide by
negative 9.8 so you divide by negative
9.8
and you get
14.8
i'll just round 14.89 seconds
so this is delta t the positive version
is equal to
14.89 seconds and so my initial comment
about yet wanting to using the positive
version was wrong because we have this
denominator of this negative so you want
the numerator to be negative and only
when the numerator is negative will the
whole expression be positive and so we
got this positive time of 14.89 seconds
i'm going to leave you there in the next
part of the video actually i might as
well just solve instead of making a new
video although this is running long so
the amount of time that we're in the air
is 14.89 seconds so if i if i were to
ask you the hor the the horizontal
displacement it's going to be the amount
of time we're in the air
times your constant horizontal velocity
and we already figured out our constant
horizontal velocity so if you want to
figure out how far
how far along the x-axis we we get
displaced we just take
this time
times
what that just means our previous answer
times this value right here times 90
cosine of 53 degrees
and that gives 806 meters so this
displacement right over here is
806 meters